Dwight Dewey Riley was born in 1971.
He was the first born of Mr. Riley,
who he never meets, and
Mrs. Riley, who was present in 1996.
Around 1978 or 79, Dewey's younger sister Tatum was born.
The Riley family lived in the Northern California town of Woodsboro.
Despite it being a small town, Dewey doesn't seem to have many friends.
Maybe his classmates moved on to San Francisco while he stayed back in the suburbs.
As a 24 year old, Dewey watched sensational or trash news show Top Story,
unaware that he would meet the host, Gale Weathers, a year later.
In September 1996, Dewey was 25 years old and in his first year as a deputy.
Despite carrying a badge and gun, he was receiving very little respect at
work and at home.
But when a gutsy murder takes place nearby, Dewey finds that he has an
opportunity to gain a little respect.
The killer, soon to be infamously known as Ghostface, was cutting through
his sister's high school.
And though he doesn't instill a lot of faith from his peers, Deputy Dewey is
going to do everything he can, even if no one else cares, because he does.
To learn how and why Dewey Riley became the hero of the Scream franchise,
how his onscreen relationship with Gale came true in real life, and what
this could mean for future Scream installments, stick around to the end of
this video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
Welcome to horror history.
Of the two characters initially destined to die in the original 1996 Scream,
it was deputy, then private citizen, then technical advisor, then Sheriff
Dewey Riley who became the hero.
David Arquette, the actor, former professional wrestler and certified
Boss Ross instructor, infused a lot of his actual self into the character of
Dewey Riley.
In an interview with Variety, he stated Dewey always had this love of
Clint Eastwood and wanting to be the sort of macho, kind of tough guy, grizzled
person, but he never was.
Is that's how I approached the character from the start? He tried to be
tough and the sheriff, but he wouldn't get the respect.
It goes back to the classic line in the first one when I wear this badge,
you treat me like a man of the law.
He's really not that person.
The desire to be a Clint Eastwood type of character is reflected in Dewey's
theme song, which was originally composed for the 1996 movie Broken Arrow.
It was used in Scream Two as a temp track, but left ultimately in the final film.
As with the music, Dewey's character was kept alive by a series
of missteps and last minute decisions.
As the franchise grew, Dewey's life was also shaped by the life of David Arquette,
helping him evolve into the cowboy hero of the franchise.
But to understand how he got there, we've got to take it back to the
Ghostface origins in the late 90s.
♪ Ominous Music ♪
On what would have been a quiet night in September, the Woodsboro Police Department
received a 911 call that would change everything and arrive on
the scene to find high school student Casey Becker gutted in a tree.
Considering Casey was in the same class as Dewey's sister, this must have
hit him a little closer to home.
Dewey's early introduction to what would become known as the Woodsboro Murders
had him taking his position as deputy very seriously.
Regardless of the response from everyone
– [TATUM] Dewey was saying this is the worst crime they’ve seen in years. Even worse than-
The next morning, there's a strange feeling in the air of
Woodsboro High School.
As the media swarm the quad, the sheriff brings Dewey along to interrogate
the entire school, likely because he's the youngest member of the force and
probably has familiarity with the student body because of his sister,
– [SID] Officer Burke. Dewey.
– [DEWEY] Uh that’s Deputy Riley today, Sid.
Right off the bat, we see that Dewey is struggling to get a girl seven years
his junior to respect his title as deputy.
When interviewing Sidney Prescott, he's gently, authoritative.
It's a quality that would evolve to become both his strongest weapon and
eventually, it would be part of his downfall.
Another emergency call comes in later that evening after Sidney is attacked
in her home and Deputy Dewey is the first responder.
– [DEWEY] (screams)
Dewey stakes claim of catching Sidney's boyfriend Billy Loomis, who is found
in Sidney's house with a cell phone.
He isn't that surprised that it might be Billy. Evidence that he has the
potential instinct to catch criminals despite his Barney Fiefdom.
While Sid sits for another round of questioning conducted by Dewey, let's
examine his desk.
Cosmic Cop packaging taped to his computer monitor, orange plastic handcuffs,
a toy police car, and a squirt gun.
It's easy to imagine that these were gag gifts from the other officers,
basically mocking and hazing Dewey for being the youngest of the force.
But the cops do at least take him somewhat seriously, at least compared to
how he's treated by his sister.
– [TATUM] GodDAMN it Dewey!
– [DEWEY] What did Mom tell you? When I’m wearing this badge, you treat me like a man of the law.
– [TATUM] I’m sorry Deputy Dewey Boy but we’re ready to go. Now. Okay?
The tremble in his voice and childish need to look to a real adult to
control Tatum is perhaps the best example of where Dewey stands as a man.
– [DEWEY] He’s my superior!
– [TATUM] The JANITOR’S your superior.
An analysis of Dewey can't be done without also mentioning the franchise long
romance that developed between him and a journalist, Gale Weathers.
The first encounter of these starcrossed lovers comes as Dewey tries to
sneak Tatum and Sidney out the back door of the police station to avoid the
media and Gale ambushes Sidney while Dewey is busy pulling up the car.
- [OFF-CAMERA] Nice shot.
- [OFF-CAMERA] No, I need camera.
Despite being a fan of Gale's show, he turns a blind eye to the assault,
keeping in mind what Sidney has been through over the last year and even
brings her an ice pack for her bruised hand when she sleeps over that night.
But even with the oversight of a cop, no house with a landline is safe from Ghostface.
- [SID] Hello?
– [GHOSTFACE] Hello, Sidney.
- [SID] Leave me alone!
Considering the effort it took to get Dewey up when he had pretty much just
gone to bed, he must have been in a really deep sleep.
Or maybe just having fun with the vacuum cleaner.
- [DEWEY] Hello?
In any event, he gets there too late.
The next morning, he breaks the news to Sidney about Billy being released on
account of his phone bill being clean, and assures her that they'll find the killer.
While dropping off Tatum and Sidney at school, he formally meets Gale
for the first time.
They have a flirtatious exchange, but while there is an attraction between them,
Gale is clearly trying to manipulate him and compliments him on his chest.
- [DEWEY] Because of my boyish good looks, muscle mass has increased my
- [DEWEY] acceptance as a serious police officer.
Again, this is a theme for Dewey
throughout the franchise, he strives for authority not as a means of
control, but as a means of respect in order to best protect the people he loves.
Gale turns up the flattery, but an announcement from Principal Himbry
that suspends all classes and institutes a townwide curfew interrupts her.
Gale pushes a little too hard in their back and forth, allowing Dewey to
pick up on her insincerity and ice her out.
But the exchange still ends on a playful note.
- [DEWEY] If I may say so, Miss Weathers, you are much prettier in person.
From the beginning, Dewey saw something in Gale that no one else saw.
But after the town shuts down for curfew, Dewey would make a mistake that
would haunt him for the rest of his life.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
While Tatum and Sidney shop for snacks, Dewey treats himself to an ice cream
cone and runs into Sheriff Burke.
The image of Sheriff Burke's stress smoking while Dewey licks an ice cream
cone is a good visual reminder of Dewey's young naivete.
Sheriff Burke informs Dewey that the Ghostface calls were issued by
Neil Prescott's phone, and Dewey assures him that he'll keep an eye on Sidney.
Is his botched attempt to put on his sunglasses a foreshadowing of his
future, missteps? Maybe not, but it's still funny.
That night, he drops Sidney and Tatum off at Stu Macher's house, where the
youth of America are having a party.
But the eye he's supposed to be keeping on Sid is distracted when he runs
into Gale Weathers again.
Flustered by her presence, he foolishly allows her to join as he checks out
the party.
Upon entering, he pretends like he's going to bust a kid for underage drinking,
only to tell him that he's kidding and to have a good time.
Just as he wanted Tatum to respect him in the police station so he could be
accepted by his fellow officers, he tries to be the cool cop so he can be
liked by this group of high schoolers.
Speaking of Tatum, she is not pleased with his guest.
- [TATUM] Dewey, What is she doing here?
- [DEWEY] She's with me.
He's too excited to be seen rolling with a celebrity reporter to remember
the bad blood that Sidney has with Gale.
Tatum orders him to remove Gale before heading to the garage to get beer.
Unfortunately, this interaction is also the last time that Dewey would ever
see his sister alive.
Shortly after, he gets a report of an abandoned car up the road and uses it
as an opportunity to take Gale Weathers on a little murder night stroll.
She obliges and the two head off.
This time, the flirtation has a little bit more sincerity, and they share a
little bit about themselves while also physically getting closer.
Part of the strength of Dewey and Gale's relationship was each of them
willing to be vulnerable with each other so early on.
He even shares his real name with her, explaining that the nickname Dewey is
just something he got stuck with.
- [DEWEY] It's just this town's way of not taking me serious.
- [GALE] What about Gale Weathers? Sounds like I'm a meteorologist or something.
And speaking of Dewey's authority not being taken seriously, two cars full
of teens barrel down the road en route to turning Dewey and Gale into
pedestrian casualties, and he tries to somehow get the cars to freeze, which
is ineffective.
So he throws himself and Gale out of the way
at the last second. Lying in a ditch together, Dewey and Gale gaze at each
other before sharing their first kiss which he allows to go on momentarily
before pulling away and telling her that he's on duty.
It's a great moment of maturity for him, like earlier, when he stopped to
get ice cream while keeping an eye on Sidney.
He got distracted momentarily, but this time he quickly corrects course.
After Gale notices the abandoned car, Dewey recognizes it as Neil Prescott's,
basically concluding that Sidney's father is Ghostface and rushes with Gale
back to the party.
In the time they were gone, the party guests mostly cleared out, save for
the important characters, and the house is quiet.
Dewey instructs Gale to call for backup before charging in, gun drawn.
As he clears each room,
it's obvious he's very scared by the tremor of his gun and his fright at the
screaming coming from a movie in the other room.
It's a testament to his bravery, but also to his objective to protect and
serve, no matter the risk.
At some point, while searching the house, Stu must have snuck up on him
while under the disguise of the Ghostface mask and stuck a knife into his back.
But even that doesn't stop him from trying to respond to Sidney's
screams for help.
Keyword... trying.
- [SID] Dewey!
And that was the end of Deputy Dwight Dewey Riley or it would have
been if David Arquette hadn't been so good in the role.
As original writer Kevin Williamson recounted during the course of the
movie, we realized how his performance was just so witty.
He played it with such heart, such commitment, and everyone kept thinking
that about halfway through it, they were asking me about a sequel, because I
had already written the outline.
They were like, what about the sequel? Why isn't Dewey in the sequel?
And so, just in case, we filmed that last sequence of him getting in the ambulance.
The decision to keep Dewey alive would become the major shaping
force on the entire Scream franchise and link the fictional events to our
real world through the actor David Arquette.
And it starts with what happened next.
Shortly after regaining consciousness, Dewey would have found out about his
sister's death, and I'd imagine that his failure to protect her could be
part of the reason that he decided to leave the Woodsboro police force
shortly after, along with his injuries. Due to the nerve damage on his back,
he would develop a limp.
But letting go of the badge does not mean letting go of his desire to protect.
But those who needed protection didn't stick around for long.
Sidney and Randy would seemingly graduate early and head off to Windsor College in Ohio.
Gale would take off back to New York.
After all, they did just meet two days prior. Barely.
There, she would finish up her book, The Woodsboro Murders, which
Dewey was excited to read, only to find that she had portrayed him as a
complete idiot.
The book was adapted into a movie, Stab, which Dewey doesn't show that much
interest in, despite being portrayed by David Schwimmer from Friends.
That's honestly understandable it's a movie about the worst moments of his life.
Seeing it alone with none of the other people involved wouldn't have been
much fun.
But the movie actually creates an opportunity for a reunion.
On April 13, 1997, Dewey sees a report from Windsor College in Ohio
regarding the murder of two students the night before at an early screening of Stab.
So he got on the first flight he could find, where a year ago, we'd rarely
seen him out of uniform.
This Dewey is in a baggy jacket, holding his right arm awkwardly at his side
with a heavy limp.
Judging from their reunion, Sidney and Dewey haven't seen each other in a
while. And later, Randy asks about Dewey's limp and arm, indicating that he
hadn't been in touch since The Woodsboro murders.
There may be an explanation for this, since Scream takes place in September
1996, as evidenced by these calendars, among other things.
And Scream Two takes place in April 1997, which is clearly shown on the
movie theater marquee.
We can assume that Sidney and Randy didn't make it to the end of the 96/97
high school year and instead were allowed to graduate early and go directly
to college, where they could begin on a winter term.
A change of scenery would be healthy for them, even if it means not having
time to say goodbye to Dewey.
Their reunion, however, could certainly have occurred under happier
circumstances.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
When Dewey finds Sidney at her college campus, he doesn't share what he's
specifically been doing for the last year, but it's safe to assume that it's
been a lonely one.
- [DEWEY] I was just worried.
- [DEWEY] Look, Sid, if there is some freaked out psycho trying to follow on Billy Loomis's
- [DEWEY] footsteps, you probably already know him.
- [DEWEY] Or her.
- [DEWEY] Or them.
He's completely right and even tries to make her aware to be on the lookout
for a white male, which is statistically the most probable for a serial killer.
Wait a minute.
Dewey implores Sidney to be careful and assures her that he'll be hanging
around just in case.
I always took his involvement to be kind of a cope for him.
He wasn't able to save Tatum, so he's going to try to make up for it by
saving her best friend.
Sidney has a similar take.
- [RANDY] Deputy Dewey. Woodsboro's finest.
- [RANDY] What's he doing here?
-[SID] He's worried our surrogate big brother.
It wouldn't be the last time he tried to cope using a surrogate.
It was his care for Sidney, though, that brought him out to the Midwest.
But he'd also run into someone he didn't care to see.
- [DEWEY] Page 32. Deputy Dewey filled the room with his Barney Fife-ish presence.
- [GALE] You read my book?
- [DEWEY] Yes, I do read, Miss Weathers.
- [GALE] Oh, Dewey, don't take it so seriously. It's a character in a book.
- [DEWEY] Page 41. Deputy Dewey oozed with inexperience.
To be fair, Dewey did literally the opposite of what he was told to do by
the sheriff in Woodsboro.
He left Sidney and Tatum at the party and walked off with Gale down the road.
It's all part of the ride.
But Gale had a point.
However, he feels justified in calling her money hungry and heartless.
On the other hand, he's probably the only one who can speak to Gale like
that without her going nuclear.
- [DEWEY] How do you know that my dim witted inexperience isn't merely a subtle form
- [DEWEY]  of manipulation used to lower people's expectations, thereby enhancing my ability to effectively maneuver within any given situation?
Because your sister wouldn't be dead.
Dewey is harboring a lot of pain over his characterization in Gale's book.
And who can blame it? The year before, he vented to Gale about how he was
just trying to get people to call him Dwight, or at least deputy.
And what does she do to the man who risked his life for her? She sees to it
that the whole world disrespects him by portraying him as a doofus in her
widely published book.
Talk about kicking a cripple when he's down.
And despite all of that, he still can't help himself from complimenting her hair.
- [DEWEY] Nice streaks.
That night.
Student CiCi Cooper is stabbed and thrown from the top of her sorority house
and Ghostface goes after Sidney shortly after.
Dewey gives chase.
But with his limp, Ghostface slips away after leaving a slice in Derek's arm
to remember him by.
Dewey grows suspicious of Derek's near miss and can't help but play
detective when speaking to Windsor's Police Chief.
- [DEWEY] Do you think someone's trying to duplicate Woodsboro?
- [GALE] It looks like it.
- [DEWEY] Think you have a copycat on your hands, Chief?
So Dewey does some of his own investigating. With Woodsboro survivor film expert and Windsor College
film student Randy Meeks.
The two run through possible suspects, including Derek and themselves.
Yet, Dewey balks at the idea of Gale being a suspect.
He enjoys cutting her down a little, but in the end, he's more willing to
make himself a suspect than assume that Gale is a Ghostface killer.
- [DEWEY] No, Gale's a lot of things, but Gale's not a killer.
Later on the quad, they continue sharing theories which all amount to
incredulously, accepting that these are Woodsboro copycat killings.
The first mention of Tatum by name causes Dewey to wince, confirming that
there's grief and possibly guilt still there.
Before he has time to process that, Gale gets an incoming Ghost face call of
her own, and Randy picks it up.
Seeing an opportunity, Gale and Dewey partner off, leaving Randy to keep
Ghostface on the line while they try to search for him.
After assaulting several strangers, it dawns on them that they have no idea
where Randy is while being pursued by a killer
and Randy becomes the next victim under Dewey's watch, just like Tatum
seven months prior.
That would not be the only similarity to 1996 Cotton Weary.
The number one suspect at the time is released.
Much like Billy Loomis, the campus is given an evening curfew.
Dewey swears, Cotton or not, that he'll find the guy responsible.
And just when it feels like the story might unfold just as it did before,
Gale adds a shocking twist.
She takes responsibility for herself.
- [GALE] I feel bad, Dewey.
- [GALE] I feel really bad.
- [GALE]  I never say that because I never feel bad about anything, but I feel bad now.
This is huge.
Without Gale's sincerity, the two can't fully establish the trust needed to
get them through the next couple installments.
At first, Dewey is mistrustful thinking that she's performing.
But in the end, they come together out of their mutual desire to bring the
culprit to justice.
It is perhaps their most important scene together because from here on out,
Dewey and Gale became fully intertwined in the series.
Their teamwork quickly pays off when they realize that Gale has crowd
footage shot for her story, which they realize might be an excellent place
to start looking for the killer.
A VHS viewing session in the film's lecture hall leads to Gale apologizing
for hurting Dewey's feelings, which leads to an impromptu tryst.
And like their moment together before finding Neil Prescott's car,
Gale comes to a realization.
- [GALE] Dewey, that's not my footage.
Someone is playing this additional footage on a second TV.
And inevitably, Dewey and Gale find themselves in an old fashioned Ghostface pursuit.
They end up separated, with Gale accidentally trapping herself in a recording studio.
With only one exit, she successfully dodges Ghostface.
Slipping into the soundproof side of the studio, Dewey unfortunately enters
on the other side, unaware that Ghostface is in the room.
Just as he peers through the window searching for Gale, Ghostface jams the
knife into Dewey's back with the last of his strength, the Dewey finds the
mic to yell out a warning to Gale before he is dispatched on the glass
beside her.
It seemed the events of Woodsboro past really were repeating themselves,
because once again, Dewey would find himself out of commission for the finale.
But luckily, once again, he leaves the next morning in an ambulance,
not a body bag.
We see how far Dewey and Gale's relationship has come when she immediately
drops her news microphone at the sight of him.
Unlike their previous adventure, where she was more concerned with getting the shot.
According to this first responder, it was actually Dewey's traumatic past that saved his life.
- [FIRST RESPONDER] Knife went into some old scar tissue, saved his life.
After realizing how much they cared about each other, the two would try to
make it work by living in Woodsboro, where Gale took care of him until he was well.
But Gale Weathers has never been a small town character, and she never
misses an opportunity to say this.
While Dewey can't seem to go anywhere without bringing Woodsboro with him.
If one of them wasn't willing to relocate, then it was never going to
work romantically in the long term.
After a year, Gale left to chase an opportunity on 60 Minutes 2.
Ironically, being the only core legacy character to consistently return to
Woodsboro probably made it easy for the Stab Three production team to
find him.
Sometime after Gale leaves, Dewey accepts an out of town job himself in
Hollywood, or at least Studio City.
Due to his firsthand experience, he comes onto Stab Three as a technical advisor.
This is kind of a 180 for him, considering he showed no interest in
the Stab franchise before this, but he was probably lonely after things
didn't work with Gale and the cast of this movie.
Pretending to be his friends were the closest he could have to actually
having those friends together.
Inevitably, they were not the only remnants of his past to be found on this production.
The Return of Ghostface would wreck havoc on more than just the shooting sketches.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
In July 1999, Dewey serves as a technical advisor on a recreated set version
of Woodsboro, frozen at each brutal murder, including his sisters.
Surely that can't be helpful for his grief processing.
Despite this, it's not hard to figure out why the job is attractive for him.
He has a little authority on set, plus he works most closely with actress
Jennifer Jolie, who happens to be playing Gale Weathers.
Just as Sidney had become sort of a surrogate sister for him during Scream Two,
Jennifer is his surrogate girlfriend though I'm pretty sure it's more
of an emotional surrogate than a physical one.
With Jennifer referring to Dewey as her rock, he ends up moving into a
trailer on her property, which, if you know, LA
and housing costs, is probably the nicest thing anyone's ever done for him.
Sidney has moved into a life of seclusion, with her whereabouts hidden from
everyone except Dewey, who seems to be his most focused when he knows that
she's safe.
Dewey isn't the only former Woodsboro resident on staff.
Cotton Weary is set to make a cameo in the movie as himself.
That is, until he becomes the victim of yet another Ghostface killer.
This prompts
LA Detective Mark Kincaid to hire the real Gale Weathers, seeing as how she
literally wrote the book on Ghostface, placing her directly in the path of
Dewey Riley.
- [DEWEY] Well, surprise, surprise, someone dies and Gale comes running.
This is a confident, maybe even happier, Dewey than the morose, broken man
who showed up on campus in 1997.
I'm not suggesting that living on a movie star's driveway because she
reminds him of someone he loves is the ultimate dream for him, but I think
his slightly improved state is probably tied to our main through line in this video.
After surviving two Ghostface attacks, Dewey has gained a little respect.
The actors see him as the real thing.
Dewey grins at his Tom Prince casting and Stab Three.
Despite Gale's incredulous laugh, that alone is proof that he no longer
needs to hang on her every word.
That night, Ghostface stabs again, taking out another cast member.
The next day, Dewey and Gale sit down to lunch, and Dewey looks perturbed
when she reveals that the police approached her to help investigate the new murders.
Sure, Gale wrote the definitive book on the Woodsboro murders,
but Dewey was actually a cop.
There are reasons why they might approach Gale over Dewey, like the fact
that Dewey is a part of the production and probably a suspect, but from his
point of view, he just got overlooked for the person he almost died for.
- [GALE] You said you'd never leave Woodsboro.
- [GALE] It's the only place that's real.
- [GALE] But now you're here, not with me.
It's clear that Gale did want Dewey to come with her, but in his mind, she
wanted to be someone else and didn't try to make it work in Woodsboro.
He's deflecting from the reality that it was Dewey who never tried to meet
her halfway in their romantic life.
When it comes to catching Ghostface, however, he's all in.
Off the record.
He fills Gale in on the information he has, but he's interrupted by a page
from Jennifer Jolie.
He gives Gale the same line he gave her after their first kiss.
- [GALE] Wait, Dewey, where are you going?
- [DEWEY] I'm on duty.
A distraught Jennifer catches Dewey up on
the second victim, Sarah Darling, and the pattern is revealed.
Each victim has been taken out in the same order as the deaths in the
Stab Three script, and next up is Gale, which means trouble for Jennifer.
Dewey tries to take control of the situation using the authority and respect
he's fostered as a former law enforcement hero.
However, not everyone sees him the same way he sees himself.
-[STEPHEN STONE] Hey, do drop have a word?
Jennifer's bodyguard, Stephen Stone, still speaks
down to him and reminds him who the professional celebrity guard is and who
the failed cop whose resume reads like an obituary is.
Ouch. I absolutely love the nickname Dew Drop, though.
With Stone taking care of Jennifer, Dewey joins Detective Kincaid and the
LAPD down at the Stab Three production office, where he's reminded that
there were three versions of the script, thus three different people that
could die next.
Due to all the unknowns, production on Stab Three is canceled.
So the remaining cast members all meet back at Jennifer Jolie's for a gloomy
rap party, if you want to call it that.
Turns out, gathering all the possible victims in one house wasn't the
perfect idea.
And this leads to a Ghostface attack.
Stephen Stone gets a knife in Dewey's trailer.
Who's the dew drop now? He manages to stagger out to the front door, where he
collapses in front of everybody, sending the whole cast into a panic.
Suddenly, new script pages start coming in on Jennifer's fax machine.
Dewey realizes it's a trap and orders everyone to go outside.
But his Hollywood counterpart, Tom Prince, lets his curiosity get the better
of him, which ends up being a fatal mistake.
The blast propels Dewey, Jennifer, and Gale downhill splitting the party up.
He finds himself in a real Sophie's Choice, with Jennifer calling for him
from one direction and Gale from the other.
He doesn't hesitate before marching towards Gale, the real Gale, and reaches
her just in time to fire off a shot and save her from Ghost fans.
- [GALE] Thanks for saving me.
- [DEWEY] It's habit.
The next day, Sidney finally arrives in Los Angeles, hoping to help solve
the mystery.
And shortly after, they receive a video containing the rules of surviving
the rare horror trilogy by none other than the deceased Randy Meeks.
Unlike when Randy tried to deliver the rules to him at Windsor College two
years prior and Dewey interrupted him to get to the point, this time he's
taking notes.
This really emphasizes Dewey's growing belief in the rules and thus his
willingness to learn them.
He's not just randomly searching for a killer, he's learning how they operate.
With a more focused direction provided by Randy. RIP.
Gale unsurprisingly splits off.
Do you want us to come with you? I work better alone.
No. History says you really don't.
Meanwhile, Dewey is doing his own investigating on set when he hears Sidney
calling for him.
He fights through his nerve damage to reach her as fast as he can.
But the second Dewey hobbles in Ghostface runs off.
The whole thing is a parallel of Billy's first attack on Sid and
Dewey is the first responder on the scene in both instances.
Once Sidney is settled at the precinct and following a confrontation with
Stab's producer about Maureen Prescott's past in Hollywood, Dewey, Gale and
Jennifer head off to the birthday party of Roman, the director of Stab Three,
and totally not Ghostface or Sidney's half brother.
The party splits up again because they just never learn.
But Dewey and Gale stay back to wait for Sidney to arrive, where they
discover Ghostface mask, cell phone and voice changer.
Then they split up because they just never learn.
Gale and Jennifer only manage to find him moments before he gets popped by
Ghostface, who slices him on the arm and knocks him out of commission just
long enough to take two more victims from the Stab Three cast.
As he comes to and examines his injuries, Gale brings him his gun or
someone's gun.
I've kind of lost track at this point.
And he sees the bedroom mirror moving.
He risks the seven years of bad luck by shooting through it.
And Jennifer comes crashing through the glass shards, or should I say
Jennifer's body.
Dewey is mortified to lose the cast member he connected most with, and Gale
is even more mortified to see the grim image of someone who is supposed to
be portraying her.
So they do the most logical thing anyone would do in this scenario.
Not really.
They split up again.
When he realizes he can't find her, he freaks out.
Gale calls his phone and tells him that she's trapped in the basement, but
because of the voice changer, he second guesses this, suspicious that it may
be the killer trying to lure him down there.
However, when he hears her scream movie title, he opens the basement door
anyway and Ghostface knocks him out with the dull end of a knife.
As a result, Dewey and Gale are captured by Ghostface, but luckily for them,
he keeps them alive to use as base to lure in his main target, Sidney.
And Dew Drop can only watch as Ghostface chases her into the secret
screening room, where all would be revealed.
It was Roman who is also Sidney's half brother.
Sorry I lied.
(IMPACT)
♪ Metal Music ♪
After breaking free from the chair he is bound in, Dewey frees Gale and
retrieves the gun from Detective Kincaid, who has also been injured by Roman.
Dewey ends up being the last cop standing.
Perhaps this gave him the confidence to return to the police force in the future.
Or perhaps it was the heroics that would soon follow.
After barging into the library and sticking a pair of tweezers in the outlet to turn off
the power.
Don't try that at home.
He's able to navigate the secret corridors of the mansion and ram down the
screening room door right after the conclusion of Sid's battle with Roman.
This time he demonstrates that he really was paying attention during Randy's
tape because he's the one to remind the others of the horror movie rules,
this time about the killer being superhuman at the end of a trilogy.
As usual, Randy was spot off
- [SID] Dewey.
- [DEWY] What?
- [SID]Head. Shoot him in the head.
Third time's a charm, I guess.
This time Dewey stays in the game long enough and finally gets to be the hero.
Sometime later, the group returns to Sidney's remote home in the hills
to help her settle back in, I suppose.
Knowing that this adventure is over, and with Roman gone, possibly for good,
he probably realizes that his time with Gale will be coming to a close soon.
If he doesn't make a move, he asks her to sign his copy of The Woodsboro Murders,
only when she opens it up, she finds an Andy Dufresne style proposal.
- [DEWEY] I know it'll never work.
- [DEWEY] You know it'll never work but what I'm asking you just to see if we're wrong.
They weren't wrong.
What? They weren't.
However, the two did go on to get married in 2001, and things would go well
for a while.
With the superstar limo of Scream sequels behind them.
The new millennium was much quieter and more peaceful for Dewey and Gale.
They settled down together in Woodsboro, with Gale finally giving a
chance to that dreaded small town life.
As I alluded to earlier, Dewey became a cop again, and this time he quickly
rose up through the ranks due to his extensive experience.
As years went by without a new ghost face, his younger reputation of Deputy
Dewey boy and Do Drop slowly faded to memory.
Eventually, he became Woodsboro's sheriff, finally achieving the
strongest symbol of respect he had long sought after.
Dewey maintains his care and protectiveness over his loved ones, though
Sidney is, of course, not in Woodsboro.
Regardless, he holds on to his surrogate brother role and reads Sidney's
book, Out of Darkness, cover to cover when it comes out.
As the added responsibilities of his job begin to require more of him,
cracks start to show in his relationship with Gale, who is having a hard
time finding her purpose after moving from nonfiction to fiction and
suffering from writer's block, which is made worse by the lack of a friend
network in the area.
In September 2011, and I'm basing that date on this line from Scream 2022.
Sheriff Riley wakes up and goes on his way.
But the morning begins with a haunting similarity to the night of the
Woodsboro murders, with a teenager blowing past him at an alarming speed.
It's also the anniversary of the day he lost his sister, which means kids
have decorated the town square with Ghostface paraphernalia.
He shows up to find his deputy, Judy Hicks, already at work removing them.
She's harboring a not so secret crush on Sheriff Riley, but he's staying
faithful to Gale, and if he didn't go for Jennifer Jolie when he was
single, he's probably not straying from Gale at this point.
They get a call on the radio about two teenage girls who were stabbed the
night before and quickly go to investigate.
Deputy Hicks traces a phone call from the scene of the crime to a bookstore,
which just happens to be where Sidney Prescott is doing a signing for her
new publication, Out of Darkness.
Dewey discovers evidence from the previous night's crime
planted in Sidney's rental car.
Guess she's not getting that deposit back.
Although he doesn't really suspect her, he takes Sid back to the precinct
for mandatory questioning.
And to add to the drama, he has to break up an argument between his jealous
wife and Deputy Hicks.
Gale blows up on him because she expects to be part of the investigation,
just like in the past.
But now that Dewey is sheriff, he's technically not supposed to divulge
police information to a reporter, and he's forced to send her off.
This is a major moment for Dewey.
Perhaps the biggest mistake he made in the first investigation was letting
Gale distract him while he was on duty.
Even if they are better off as a team, he's showing that he takes his
newfound responsibility seriously.
When Gale declares that she's going rogue, the expression of hurt on his
face says it all.
He's risking what's left of his relationship by sticking to the law.
Eventually, he's going to have to choose between being the perfect sheriff
or being the perfect husband.
For now, he places 24 hours police surveillance on Sidney for her protection.
But that doesn't stop the new Ghostface from taking another
teenage victim nearby.
So Sheriff Riley finds himself in the unenviable position of telling his
community it's going to be fine, when he very much knows it may not be.
As the killer would immediately demonstrate when Sidney's literary publicist is
thrown off a parking garage in the middle of his press conference.
Although being sheriff in the midst of a Scream movie is basically a lose
lose situation, it's cool to see Dewey in action, calling the shots.
He's come a long way from the 25 year old taking orders and doing grunt work.
However, his position requires him to conduct himself in a certain
manner, as opposed to Gale, who can use less orthodox methods.
Dewey later receives a call from her as she's staking out the Stabathon Film Fest,
a gathering of high school film buffs to celebrate the Stab franchise,
and she thinks the killer is about to strike.
He mocks her from needing his help after going rogue, causing her to pout
and hang up.
He immediately realizes the danger she's in and rushes to her location, only
to find her car, where he spots Ghostface sneaking up on her on the monitor.
Unable to do anything about it, he rushes into the barn where Stabathon is
being held and fires a shot in the mass killer's direction, but not before
Ghostface takes the name of the event literally and stabs Gale in the shoulder.
Dewey's concern for his wife trumps his need to catch the killer,
so he attends to her as Ghostface gets away, jogging next to Gale as she's
wheeled to an ambulance, Dewey has an epiphany!
Perhaps thinking over the two times Gale had to do
the same for him, that is, watching him go away on a stretcher, Dewey makes a pledge.
- [DEWEY] No more on your own.
- [DEWEY] It's you and me forever.
Not a promise he could keep. Anyway.
Deputy Hicks calls with more grim news.
Sidney's aunt, Kate Roberts, has lost her life along with two of Dewey's
officers, Haas and Perkins.
Without hesitation, Sheriff Riley hits the lights, cues the siren, and
speeds off to meet Judy at
Mrs. Roberts, which is not the right spot, as he finds out when he gets a
panicked phone call from Sidney, who explains that she's at Kirby Reed's
house and the killer is in the vicinity.
Notice how Sidney doesn't call 911.
She just calls Dewey directly.
I hope to have that level of notoriety one day.
I mean, I do.
I do.
Right now.
Don't !#$@! with me.
Dewey orders Deputy Judy to send all units to three two nine Whispering Lane.
Dewey is no longer the lone cowboy he once was, but this new pair of
killers are a different breed than Billy Loomis and Stu Macher were, and the
brigade of officers could not possibly contend with what they would find.
(IMPACT)
♪ Ominous Music ♪
Dewey and the police arrive, only to find out that they were too late.
When they get to Kirby's house, they find nothing but a living room full of victims.
Or so it seems.
The survivors, Jill, Sidney, and Kirby, are transferred to the hospital.
The only one who is conscious is Jill, and she has an oddly unenthusiastic
reaction to learning that Sidney was still alive.
This doesn't showcase Dewey's ineptitude as much as it highlights how he and
Gale really do work better together than apart, which is proven shortly after.
When Dewey stops by her room.
- [DEWEY] She asked if you were okay.
- [DEWEY] She thinks you guys should write a book together with your matching wounds.
- [GALE] Why she was stabbed in the shoulder. How did she know I was, too?
Dewey and Gale realize it at the same time.
Jill would not know where Gale's stab wound was unless she was in league
with the one who created it.
He rushes back to Sidney's room, where he's greeted with a bedpan to the
face and beaten down until he's out cold like his first two goarounds with
Ghostface, he stays down for the entire finale.
What hit me? Don't ask.
But for the fourth time now, the trio, this time accompanied by Deputy Hicks,
are able to take down their deranged adversaries.
He may not have realized it at the time, but this was the tail end of the
golden era of Dewey Riley.
He has Gale, Sidney is safe, and he has a competent deputy working for him
in Hicks.
He and Gale recommitted to each other, but at some point over the next
decade, Gale's claustrophobia pertaining to small town America creeped up
and threatened their relationship once more.
This time it was Dewey who had to make concessions, and he left his hometown
behind to move to New York City, where Gale would become the host of Good
Morning with Gale Weathers for all of about two months before giving up on
the marriage to return to Woodsboro.
For someone who's supposed to be the bravest character in the franchise, he
doesn't do too well outside of his comfort zone.
Whereas Gale lasted more than twelve years outside of hers, his old job was
waiting for him, probably held in the interim by Deputy Judy Hicks, as you
would expect for the man who is basically a Woodsboro folk hero.
But the split from Gale seems to just break him with his growing disconnect
from the people he crafted his identity around.
He becomes a hermit and moves into a dingy trailer in the outskirts of town.
I guess he was used to the trailer life from his time on Jennifer Jolie's
driveway, but it's still a downgrade from the big house he once shared with Gale.
Dewey has a habit of revisiting the worst moments of his life, and
he's had quite a few.
He also becomes an alcoholic, and it seems that his personal issues began to
affect his work, and eventually he was asked to resign from the Woodsboro
Police Department and Deputy Hicks was promoted to sheriff.
Hicks after spending his whole life trying to earn respect, they finally
stripped the last accolade he had to his name.
Life became pretty sad for Dewey.
With his sister's ashes on his mantle, the only thing he had to look forward
to every day was seeing his ex wife's show on TV.
With no Ghostface and no one he cared about to protect, Dewey felt that he
had lost his purpose.
He continued to sink deeper until 2021, 25 years since Billy Loomis and
Stu Macher first asked what's your favorite scary movie? Opportunity would
come knocking at his door.
Samantha Carpenter and her boyfriend, and definitely not Ghostface Ritchie,
come around looking for an expert in regards to a new set of Ghostface attacks.
Experts don't typically fare well in scream.
Just ask Randy, Meeks, Charlie, and Robbie.
The fact that they want to talk to him so badly, even when he doesn't want
to get involved, illustrates that because of his experiences, he still has
the respect of the younger generation who desperately need his help.
This is a small win for Dewey, but he's still skeptical.
-[DEWEY] Give me one good reason why I should talk to you.
-[SAM] I'm Billy Loomis's daughter.
-[DEWEY] That's a terrible reason for me to talk to you.
While this is a Dewey broken as we have ever seen him before, his
sympathetic side gets the better of him, and he gives them a couple of
minutes to lay down the rules.
-[DEWEY]  There are certain rules to surviving a Stab movie.
-[DEWEY] Believe me.
-[DEWEY] I know.
-[DEWEY] Rule number one never trust the love interest.
He's on the money with that.
After initially being skeptical before adopting the rules in Hollywood,
Dewey is now a believer.
He even seems to have mastered the art of writing the rules.
-[DEWEY]  Rule number two the killer's motive is always connected to something in the past.
-[SAM] I'm related to Billy.
Yep. Sam is being set up solely because of her blood relation to Billy Loomis.
-[DEWEY] Rule number three, and this is the most important rule the first
-[DEWEY] victim always has a friend group that the killer is a part of.
Damn. This is the first time a character has ever been 100% correct with the rules.
Usually the rules are more of a best practices rather than something
set in stone.
Sam requests Dewey's help, but he wants to stay far away from the danger.
-[DEWEY] Are you kidding me? I've been stabbed nine times.
-[DEWEY] I've got permanent nerve damage and a fun little limp.
-[DEWEY] You think I want to do that again?
Nine times so far.
But after some tough contemplation, he makes a call to Sidney, letting her
know that it's happening again and warning her to stay safe and stay away.
Not knowing that he has resigned from the police, she assumes that Dewey is
going to be protecting the next generation of victims, which makes him
reconsider his own actions.
Was shutting Sam and Ritchie out when he could potentially help really
something that Dwight Riley would do next? He has to man up and call the ex
Gale. So he texts, of course, Ghostface is back.
Don't come here.
Hope you're doing well.
He begins to type out I still, and we never see what he's still.
But we can safely assume he was about to say, I still have your copy of the
Woodsboro murders with all of the pages cut through the center.
What would you like me to do with it? It must have been Sidney's words.
Combined with the fact that he has nothing else to do in his life that
convinced Dewey to pull out his trusty old handgun.
Resting on the same mantle of remembrance as his tribute to Tatum and photo
of Gale, he's symbolically reaching into the past one more time.
He somehow finds where Sam and Ritchie went and offers his assistance.
He finds himself in a suspect roundup at the home of Mindy and Chad Meeks,
the niece and nephew of his old pal Randy, where naturally, Dewey is
suggested that the suspect
-[DEWEY] But what's my motive?
-[CHAD] You got stabbed a billion times, got dumped by your famous wife, and crawled into a bottle.
-[CHAD] I think it's safe to say you're on the suspect list.
-[DEWEY] Well, maybe you're the killer because that cut deep.
Ouch. At least he didn't call him Dewdrop, though.
Dewey catches up on the attack so far, and the theme this time is familial
connections to the past.
Tara was the first to be attacked, and her half sister is billy Loomis's
daughter, so she was also attacked.
They both survived, but Stu Macher's nephew Vince wasn't so lucky.
The pattern would continue later that day when Sheriff Judy Hicks and her
son Wes are both killed in broad daylight.
Dewey shows up at the crime scene to grieve for his former deputy and friend
and perhaps do a little bit of investigating on his own.
It is here where he's spotted by Gale, with the pressure of a new Ghostface
investigation forge renewed bonds between them, or would the reunion lead to
more fighting? Dewey was quickly going to find out.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
As is the tradition of their relationship, Dewey and Gale reunite under
morbid circumstances.
- [GALE] Text.
- [DEWEY] Ow.
- [GALE] Tell me the killer's back in a text.
- [DEWEY] Ow. That hurts.
- [GALE] Good!
He tries to justify it by saying she was on the air at the time.
And when he spots a camera crew with her jabs back, criticizing her for
falling back into her old ways of trying to capitalize on tragedy for a good
news story.
It's the same argument they've had since they met back in 1996.
Though fittingly, they're wearing the same colors that they wore when they
were first formally introduced, where there was excitement in that first
meeting. This reunion is tinged with sadness and regret.
Dewey expresses his shame at not being able to last in New York City and
taking off in the middle of the night.
The worst thing you can be in Dewey's mind, other than a murderer, is a coward.
- [GALE] You are a lot of things, Dewey, but you are not a coward.
- [GALE] You just were meant to be in Woodsboro.
That might not be it, because he is in Woodsboro and doing worse than
ever without his old friends there with him.
He's living in a cemetery of everything he's lost.
As Gale goes on camera for her report, it dawns on Sam that no one's at the
hospital keeping an eye on Tara, much like Dewey didn't keep an eye on
Sidney in 1996 or Randy in 1997.
And the two speed off, hoping to get there before somebody else does.
In the car, Dewey listens in as Sam calls Ritchie, but ends up reaching
someone with the infamous Ghostface voice on the other line instead, who
gives her the choice of who will survive her boyfriend or her sister.
She stalls as they park and get in the elevator up towards Tara's room.
- [GHOSTFACE] Maybe you're too weak for this franchise.
- [TARA] Maybe you're right.
- [TARA] Or maybe I'm just stalling for time.
She probably shouldn't have said that.
If Tara and the killer didn't happen to be right on the other side of the
elevator door, her sister would have been screwed.
Lucky for them, when the doors slide open, Dewey sees someone in a Ghostface
costume and fires off a couple of shots, which are evaded.
So Dewey and Ghostface engage in melee, slamming each other around glass flying,
Looking back on this, the person in the Ghostface costume during the
scene must be Amber, who is only 110 pounds or 49 kg throwing all 161 pounds or 73 kg of Dewey
off her with some kind of judo roll.
And they said Scream Three was supposed to have the quote unquote
supernatural killer.
Speaking of which, his Scream Three experiences would come back to haunt him
here. At first, Dewey gets the upper hand.
- [DEWEY] Not today.
He headbutts her backwards and grabs the gun, firing three shots into her body.
Dropping Amber into a bookcase.
Dewey quickly escorts Sam, Tara and Ritchie to the elevator before
remembering the advice that Sidney gave him to help defeat Roman more than
20 years beforehand.
- [DEWEY]  You have to shoot them in the head? They always come back.
- [SAM] Dewey. Who gives a !@#$.
- [DEWEY] I do.
And the doors close, leaving Dewey alone.
He turns and unholsters his gun, reloading as he walks, Clint Eastwood
probably on his mind.
Stepping over broken glass to Ghostface's prone form, Dewey aims when his
cell phone rings.
It's Gale.
The momentary distraction gives Amber just enough time to counter burying
one knife into his gut and the other fittingly into the same spot on his
back that Stumacher and Deborah Loomis had scarred in the past.
She tears her knives from Dewey's body simultaneously and kicks his lifeless
body to the ground.
Initially, the way he was carried out on the stretcher made me think he
would survive.
After all, we've seen him exit a Scream movie in similar fashion before.
But then you start to realize you take someone to the hospital to treat an
injury, not away from it.
Dewey is headed to the morgue.
Amber later explains that they had to kill Dewey to give their inevitable
stab movie some weight and try to prove that this wasn't just another cash
grab sequel.
Given the medicine and the nature of Scream we can assume that Dewey's
passing was an intentional move by the new writers and director to give
their movie safe and help launch a brand new chapter of Scream.
Dewey's death was devastating for his surrogate family, Sidney and Gale.
For 25 years, it had been Dewey who showed up for them.
The only people his death could have possibly been more devastating for were
his fans.
Not since Randy Meeks had the fandom been so incensed and shocked at a
Scream death.
And it was because of the actor David Arquette's parallels with the
character Dewey Riley that made him feel so real for the audience.
David Arquette put a lot of himself into Dewey and his life began to
parallel that of the fictional character he portrayed.
David met his eventual wife, Courtney Cox, aka.
Gale Weathers at a pre party before the filming of the original screen.
Like their onscreen personas, they fell in love.
But it was not all smooth sailing.
A year later, in midJune 1997 Courtney allegedly detested him on the set of
Scream Two.
Like Dewey and Gale, David and Courtney are very different people.
Scream Two makes references to Cox's friends costars David Schwimmer and
Jennifer Aniston probably an intentional reference considering the romantic
animosity between Dewey and Gale.
Scream Two also features Dewey working with local law enforcement and
Sheriff Hartley is played by David Arquette's dad, Louis Arquette.
The Arquette family has been in the film industry for generations.
In August of 1997, David's mother, Brenda Olivia Marty would pass away from
breast cancer creating another emotional link to Dewey whose mother, Mrs.
Riley, is never mentioned again.
In the series, Scream Three had Dewey and Gale finding their way back to
each other by the end and committing the relationship to marriage.
Sure enough, in real life, David Arquette and Courtney Cox were married one
month before Scream Three began filming in 1999.
Dewey's statement about them never working because they're too different was
a reality that David was facing with Courtney.
David once said he was the live wire and Courtney was his grounding force.
Then, on April 26, 2000, David Arquette would very controversially become
the world championship wrestling heavyweight champ.
His belt status would be hotly debated by wrestling fans with David Arquette
treated as a joke.
The belt was considered by most to be a publicity stunt for Arquette's
wrestling movie Ready to Rumble and David did not gain the respect of real
professional wrestlers, whatever that means.
However, Arquette was completely serious in his efforts as a professional
wrestler and fought very hard to prove himself almost to his death.
Respect became a through line in his life just as it did in Dewey's.
A decade later, Arquette's marriage to Courtney Cox was crumbling and they
were in couples therapy by the time that the fourth Scream was released.
The gulf of emotional distance between them is reflected in Dewey and Gale
from the top of Scree form yes, I pronounce things.
How they are spelled.
Their relationship problems in the movie are capped by an intense vow by
Dewey to never leave her again.
IRL, it was just a few months after shooting in October 2010 when David and
Courtney were separated.
The next decade wouldn't be any easier than the last.
In 2011, he entered rehab for alcohol and drugs and in 2013, he and Courtney
are legally divorced.
Once again.
This is all reflected in The Fifth Scream which gives details about
Dewey Riley crawling into a bottle and ending his marriage with Gale.
Reflecting on their divorce, David Arquette stated on the inside of our
rings, it says, A deal's a deal.
He says, I felt really abandoned at that point, like she'd broken the deal.
Although it was reversed in the movie, for some reason, Dewey was the one to
leave her.
David's life took another mournful turn when his sister Alexis Arquette died
in September of 2018.
Two months later, David, still in his bid to earn the respect of the
pro wrestling world was sliced in the neck when his opponent smashed a light
tube over his head in a live match in La.
With concerns David could bleed to death.
He was rushed to the emergency room.
Obviously, he survived to go on to be in Scream 2022 but his character in
that movie really did bleed to death in the ER.
I had this one therapy session where I was talking about my parents marriage
and how it was so hard on them.
Then I realized both of my parents are dead and all of this pain is living
inside me.
It was Scream 2022 that reunited Courtney and David on screen.
In real life, they're connected by their daughter.
In the movie, they are connected by their past.
So there are some real emotions flowing in the scene where they come face to face.
In an article by New York Times, Arquette acknowledged that being in a
movie with Cox again was inherently awkward.
It's been 25 years of our lives, he said.
We've grown up together.
We have a child together.
He explained, however, that he could not pass it up.
It's a cathartic experience just to be able to act opposite Courtney.
When the cameras rolled on their first scene together it was a tearful
moment and not just because the script called for it.
Cox said of Arquette,
He got very emotional while he was filming it.
He said the next day, the crew didn't look at him.
It's insane how invested David Arquette is with the character of Dewey Riley.
Those are real photos of Arquette and Cox from their real
relationship on the mantle in Scream 2022.
Scream was built on metacommentary and became the flagship for Metacinema.
Grief was already an unspoken theme in Scream and is now almost an entire
genre on its own.
With films like Midsommar, Hereditary, The VVitch and
- [TARA] The Babadook, its' an amazing meditation on motherhood and grief.
Dewey became the Scream representative of grief and his real life
counterpart, David Arquette walked down that same road alongside him.
In addition to the wrestling incident there were many times that David
almost bit the dust himself including a car crash and a heart attack like
his father and grandfather before him.
Talking to Variety, Arquette had to say this on the controversial final scene.
I mean, you can't take Sidney.
Sidney is a survivor, and there was something noble about it for Dewey.
He was there to protect Sidney and the people of Woodsboro.
There was a scene between Dewey and Gale and there was a take they didn't
use where I was super emotional.
I sort of adlibbed, I'm a failure.
I couldn't save Judy.
I couldn't save my sister.
I think it was actually too emotional.
Like, it was too much.
And a lot of that emotion that I was going through at that time was mourning
a loss.
The loss of Wes was heavy on our hearts, especially in that scene.
The only reason Dewey even made it long enough to become the hero be
respected by the fandom and become an authority within the franchise is due
to David Arquette's own drive to be better and earn respect.
I'm sure the OG 90s fandom will probably never stop imagining different
scenarios that bring Dewey back as they have for Randy.
But no matter how you slice it, pun intended, Dewey was meant to die in
Scream 2022.
Against all odds and maybe sense, he became the Clint Eastwood of Scream.
The town hero riding out on his bronco to rid the west of Ghostface.
If you want more information on the meta insanity that is Scream, click on
that playlist on the left for my analysis of characters like Randy, Billy
Loomis, Casey Becker, and others.
Remember to subscribe to CZ's World for new horrors every week, unless it
gets held up in review again.
Ring the death bell for all notification, and I'll see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.